après plusieurs semaines de chantier la
maison de bertrand à frasne le château
bénéficie du label b sur le tableau
énergétique une amélioration sensible
grâce à une série de travaux tels que le
changement complet des huisseries
c'était d'ailleurs la seule rénovation
envisagée au départ par le propriétaire
mais grâce aux conseils de la der à
associations liées à l' ademe
le chantier a pris une toute autre
tournure on vous a proposé un ensemble
de travaux à réaliser
et puis avec eux
les aides de l'anah de la région donc le
programme effilogis et et puis le crédit
d'impôt il s'est avéré qu'on avait des
subventions à hauteur de 55% et on a pu
réaliser donc le bouquet de travaux que
vous avez pu voir avec l'isolation des
combles la totalité des ouvertures et
également toute l'électricité la pause
une vmc une vmc placés dans les combles
comme il se doit des combles
parfaitement isolé après la projection
de 37 cm de ouate de cellulose ce
matériaux de grande qualité plus
efficace que la laine de verre un
chantier accompli dans les règles de
l'art de façon à prévenir tout risque de
pont thermique grâce à la pause
préalable d'une membrane entre les
solives mais aussi tout incident lié à
l'échauffement de boîtiers électriques
parfaitement localisés et protégé entre
chaque solives il ya un gros travail de
préparation de fait ensuite une fois que
ce travail était fini
il ya eu le soufflage de ouate de
cellulose sur sur toute la surface et en
finissant on a fini par un plancher
technique sur la partie centrale pour
que le client puisse heures accéder à
ces combats au départ le seul changement
des huisseries fouiteh 12500 euros
or la facture totale des travaux
avoisine les quarante mille euros c'est
27002 plus sauf que cette somme a été
quasiment remboursés grâce aux
différentes subventions obtenues dans
tous les chapitres des devis une manne
récoltée par cet expert de la der à
l'association depuis une quinzaine
d'années s'est spécialisé dans l'analyse
des dotations disponible grâce aux
politiques d'encouragement à la
rénovation du bâti ancien mais la
condition pour réussir ce tour de force
c'est de présenter le plus tôt possible
son projet de restauration intérêt de
venir nous voir assez tôt c'est qu'on
pourra dès le début vous l'idée sur les
travaux à réaliser et que demandait
aussi aux artisans que vous allez faire
intervenir pour faire des devis
donc ça permet d'aller d'aller plus vite
au but si on veut et d'avoir des devis
qui sont rapidement
quoique tu au final les incitations à la
rénovation sont aussi nombreuses qu il y
a deux projets dans ce dédale
administratif et technique
le recours à un technicien de l'ademe et
décisif pour employer une image c'est la
fondation dans le programme des travaux